[Música]
o escogí como título de estos minutos
que voy a conversar hoy con ustedes el
valor de la incertidumbre definiendo la
incertidumbre como algo que no sabemos
qué va a suceder la incertidumbre como
el no tener la probabilidad de que algo
va a ocurrir de alguna manera
y hoy que estamos intentando reescribir
nuestra identidad siento desde mi visión
que si hay una palabra que nos define en
estos tiempos es la incertidumbre
nuestra identidad en uno de los matices
de el concepto de identidad podríamos
decir que es la manera como pensamos que
otras personas nos ven la manera como
pensamos que otras personas perciben que
somos nosotros cuando conversan con
nosotros cuando nos escuchan o cuando
nos tratan
y estos tiempos también están definiendo
de una manera particular nuestra
identidad
la identidad hoy he estado escuchando
varias visiones de ella pero la
identidad
termina alejándose del concepto rígido
con el que crecimos la identidad no es
un
[Música]
una obra de bronce que está por allí y
que no se puede modificar no es un
cuadro una obra de arte a la que no se
puede tocar sino que se puede ver
observar e interpretar la gente la
identidad
va cambiando la identidad termina siendo
en resumen
los cambios que nosotros sufrimos día a
día las ambigüedades y la manera como
eso en lo más profundo nos modifica por
eso pienso que si algo en este momento
nos está marcando el camino
la incertidumbre pero cuando se habla de
la identidad como como nación que tiene
muchas aristas una de ellas siempre fue
el culto a la belleza el resultado
internacional que obtenía venezuela con
nuestras reinas un trabajo logrado por
muchísimos años por el miss venezuela en
mi nombre se hizo público y mi imagen se
hizo pública en el año 2002 precisamente
porque yo también fui miss venezuela y
también me convertí en una protagonista
de una de las aristas que definía
nuestra identidad y también fui fuera
del país a tratar de defender esa arista
de nuestra identidad como protagonista
y yo recuerdo perfectamente como muchos
jóvenes de mi generación y de
generaciones anteriores
soñaban cientos de ellas con también ser
protagonistas de esa arista de nuestra
identidad ser reinas figurar que su
nombre fuese conocido algunas porque eso
les hacía ilusión simplemente otras como
yo por que visualizaban en ello la
oportunidad de una prosperidad honesta
ciertamente era una oportunidad que se
le brindaba a todas las reinas o que
todas las reinas la tuvieron podía una
mujer que se convirtiera en
missvenezuela sentir que de cierta
manera tenía un futuro asegurado porque
sabía que las marcas iban a pelearse que
esa mujer pues a su imagen por mucho
tiempo encontraba también en el mundo
del entretenimiento la garantía si
demostraba las ganas de hacerlo y si
demostraba el talento para hacerlo tenía
en el área del entretenimiento la
garantía de que eso iba a convertirse en
un sustento no sólo para ella sino para
sacar adelante una familia para ayudar
para hacer próspero para para ganar
mucho dinero
y ciertamente la industria de la
televisión era capaz de convertirte en
una estrella había una maquinaria que lo
hacía si tú tenías el talento la
maquinaria estaba allí y tenía tenías
todo a tu disposición lo mismo ocurría
en la industria de la televisión para la
producción de telenovelas que también
formaba parte de nuestra identidad toda
latinoamérica disfrutaba de las
producciones que se hacían aquí en
venezuela y el mundo entero disfrutaba
de muchas de las producciones que
'venezuela como ejemplo de latinoamérica
lograba exportar y traducir a todos los
idiomas hay una anécdota interesante que
logró que rctv cuando la telenovela
kassandra se estaba viendo en el mundo
entero
no recuerdo exactamente en qué país pero
se paralizaba viendo la novela traducida
ciertamente será un terreno que nos
ofrecía todos la garantía de que íbamos
bien íbamos por buen camino y de un
momento a otro de dos décadas para acá
esa época de oro desapareció así como
sentimos que el piso que todos
conocíamos en distintas profesiones
desapareció lo mismo podemos decir de la
industria musical pero este caso se
repite en cada uno de los profesionales
que nuestro país consiguió con mucho
sacrificio con mucha mística obtener
varios títulos y que en este momento
está sintiendo que todo eso está allí
engavetado pero que nada de eso
garantiza el cómo sostener ni siquiera
la vida propia ni la de su familia pero
crecimos pensando que si estudiamos lo
suficiente que si nos preparábamos lo
suficiente y si por años nos dedicábamos
a hacer carrera en alguna corporación
teníamos un futuro asegurado que el
hacer carrera que en el momento en que
te retirarás bueno eso iba a ser
suficiente para mantenerte a ti ya tus
hijos ya tus nietos
yo crecí creyendo que si yo tenía una
alcancía y metía moneditas allí y la
rompía al final de año con eso que iba a
romper el alcance y al final de año iba
a poder comprar algo que yo quisiera
también crecí formada por un concepto
dentro del colegio que todavía se
mantiene en el que te repiten que si tú
durante toda tu carrera ahorras el 10%
de tus ingresos
tú tienes asegurado un futuro y que la
cultura del ahorro es una cultura
importante de cultivar y de mantener
nada eso en este momento se cumple por
eso insisto en que el piso que
conocíamos ya no está y que en este
momento nos está definiendo la
incertidumbre y esto es devastador
realmente es devastador para todos los
profesionales con tanta dedicación
que con tanta mística se dedicaron a
esto y que hoy también es innegable que
somos un país de profesionales
completamente empobrecidos
pero paradójicamente también observamos
en estos tiempos que hay alquimistas
haciendo de la incertidumbre cosas
grandiosas y que tendrán estos
alquimistas que otros no tienen que
otros no identifican
venezuela también está haciendo
referencia por ser uno de los países
donde todos escuchamos hablar hablar de
emprendimiento todos los días
definitivamente venezuela está haciendo
referencia en emprendimiento nos falta
muchísimo más nos falta seguirnos
armando de competencias pero que hace la
diferencia de dónde salen esos
alquimistas en la en la incertidumbre
tienen competencias dentro de sí o están
desarrollando competencias dentro de sí
para que para las cuales la mayoría no
se preparó
y ahora nos damos cuenta de cuán
importante es desarrollar esas
competencias
la competencia de la inteligencia
emocional cuando la mayoría de los
adultos nunca escuchamos hablar en
nuestra formación de este tipo de
competencias ni que era importante
controlar las emociones que era
importante identificar las emociones en
el otro eso no lo sabíamos la
competencia de la creatividad que dentro
de los eslabones de las características
que debe tener un buen empleado en estos
tiempos en el mundo la creatividad está
de tercer lugar cuando antes estaba por
ahí por el 10
la competencia de saber moverse en aguas
que cambian todos los días como las que
tenemos aquí la competencia de
identificar en la ambigüedad también una
oportunidad de seguir identificando
oportunidades colándonos por las grietas
por las rendijas de la crisis
y todo esto a los adultos nos ha tocado
descubrirlo pero no tenemos tal vez lo
que la hemos identificado estamos
haciendo experimentos sobre ella y
tratando de profesionalizar lo que se
nos va ocurriendo como ideas pero
tenemos todas las herramientas para
enseñársela a estas generaciones que
vienen detrás de nosotros que están
creciendo en esta crisis y que ven el
futuro
muy cortico como una nube de polvo
completa que no te permite ver más allá
de lo que estamos viviendo ahora las
generaciones que vienen detrás de
nosotros lo sienten aún peor ni siquiera
tienen la capacidad de contrastar esto
cuál es nuestra responsabilidad en este
momento y por eso estoy trabajando cómo
está trabajando muchísima gente y cuál
es mi propuesta con estos minutos que
estoy conversando con ustedes mi
propuesta es que sepamos cómo descubrir
el valor dentro de la incertidumbre
porque la incertidumbre cuando sacamos
de lo más adentro lo último que nos
quedaba
ese residuo pero el más valioso el que
atesoramos en la incertidumbre lo
tenemos que sacar lo tenemos que poner
con fe y tenemos que poner en práctica
todo nuestro ser para poder movernos y
adaptarnos al cambio para poder seguir
manteniendo el entusiasmo en momentos
complejos para entender que la
ambigüedad y que las informaciones
cruzadas y que los cambios y que cuando
cuando estamos intentando adaptarnos a
algo y todavía no nos hemos adaptado nos
cambian las señas y poder mantenernos a
flote ante eso es descubrir el valor
dentro de la incertidumbre por eso como
les decía a muchas personas lo están
haciendo yo también yo estoy proponiendo
que estas competencias de las que he
hablado hoy y también el ponerle mucho
interés a desarrollar los talentos
creativos de los jóvenes porque si yo
decía hace muchos años
con respecto a mis compañeras que iban a
estudiar carreras tradicionales que yo
iba a vivir tal vez de conversar por un
micrófono los adultos me iban a decir
bueno ahí está la que se va a morir de
hambre
y los que si van a ser exitosos son los
que se van a dedicar a competencias o a
estudios tradicionales es el momento de
nosotros conversar esto con los más
jóvenes con las generaciones
que vienen detrás de nosotros con los
adolescentes y con los niños enseñarlos
en primer lugar adaptarse a los cambios
a desarrollar en ellos competencias en
las que en los momentos complejos sepan
cómo actuar y reforzar les lo importante
que es desarrollar una inteligencia
emocional y lo importante que es confiar
en sus talentos y ser creativos y que
con lo que más les apasione intenten
profesionalizarlo porque estos tiempos
nos están dando nos están haciendo que
nos demos cuenta de que esas personas
las que son creativas las que le
apuestan con verdad con fe y que son
capaces de adaptarse a los cambios son
las que se están manteniendo a flote
nosotros vivimos una época dorada que ya
no la tenemos yo siento que en este
momento y es un nombre arbitrario que le
pongo pero siento que esta es una época
de arcilla o de barro quizá la más
primitiva de las épocas
o que podemos sentir que es así
pero el barro y la arcilla tienen una
nobleza tiene la nobleza de edificar y
nosotros a través de este momento de
incertidumbre podemos ser capaces de
edificar otra vez una época de oro
porque esta época así como pasó la de
oro está también va a pasar esto también
pasará muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]